je me suis fait beaucoup d'ennemis
il ya des survêt
même une veuve c'est pas une bonne
novembre
10 au boss que c'est noël avant l'heure
salut je vais te tuer une par tête on va
avoir besoin d'un tas de flèches à de
piéger
[Applaudissements]
ça va être le meilleur noël de notre
vitesse
j'ai emmené les enfants à new york
d'avoir une comédie musicale
moi je trouve ça super et ensuite des
types ont essayé de nous tuer
quand on y pense c'est pas vraiment
super
[Musique]
on va te falloir encore une journée ou
deux
les choses se sont légèrement compliqué
c'est sûr que vous allez à tracer
évidemment
[Musique]
bon
on est à court de flèches classique
donc ça c'est des flashs à tête piégée
vous avez encore plus balle est que ça
sérieux
[Musique]
or tu parles d'un joyeux noël